el primer día de la semana santa podría
haber sido funesto una explosión cerca
de una catedral católica sacudió este
barrio en makassar indonesia llena de
gente que iba a la misa de domingo de
ramos fue una explosión fuerte que hizo
temblar todo hasta que se rompieron las
ventanas del hotel de al lado
tras ser interceptado por un guardia de
seguridad un terrorista suicida detonó
sus explosivos en la puerta provocando
varios heridos las autoridades tienen a
dos sospechosos las muertes podrían
haber sido mucho más altas si la
explosión no hubiera sucedido en la
puerta principal de la iglesia y no en
la lateral órganos y pata pasó durante
el cambio de turno de las plegarias
el atacante intenta la iglesia y uno de
los guardias son todos los que nos hayan
manejado acceso a tu jean mentor y kaká
los periodos festivos como la pascua son
un momento particularmente arriesgado
para indonesia que vive con la amenaza
terrorista desde hace unos años los
peores ataques fueron los bombardeos de
bali en 2002 por el mayor grupo
yihadista de indonesia
jemaah islamiyah leal al qaeda
pero hay otros grupos más pequeños como
llama anexar un aula inspirado en el
grupo estado islámico en 2018 atacaron
tres iglesias y policías matando más de
30 personas y en 2017 atacaron un
starbucks en yakarta dejando ocho
muertos y docenas de heridos